we would like to say on behalf of the
whole combined team from cyprus in the
UK on behalf of the family of this young
girl that we are firstly relieved that
she's finally coming home this has been
an incredibly sad and tragic kiss for a
young teenage girl from Derbyshire a
once happy and gregarious young girl
like so many Aboriginal came over to
Cyprus with all the excitement of a
young traveler and with high aspirations
to attend University thereafter she was
actually on the cusp of embarking upon a
new chapter in her life but on to the
most dire circumstances she went
overnight from being victim to being the
accused having to ensure not only the
dreadful physical violation of a
premeditated gang rape and serious
sexual assault perpetrated upon her but
also the prolonged mental ordeal onto
the judicial process and Cyprus she was
then accused of the offence of public
mischief and that this was all a lie to
the place she is and remains adamant of
her innocence of that she has told the
truth and wife's we welcome today the
fact that the sentence imposed allows
her to go home we strongly contest the
conviction and the fight for her
innocence will go on regardless and I
can tell you now that we will be
appealing the conviction and we will be
taking this case to the Supreme Court of
Cyprus we're prepared to fight this case
all the way to the European Court of
Human Rights
we're delighted with the support we have
received from the UK and of course the
sadness imposed by the judge today was
one of four months imprisonment
suspended for three years and we know
that that he stated that he was giving
her a second chance but what we saying
and we will maintain is that this young
girl was stripped both of her dignity
and her basic human rights she has been
diagnosed with PTSD the case has
resulted in the deterioration of her
mental health in fact there were real
worries about how she could cook and
carry on throughout the legal process
and with immense support given by her
loving family her good friends and legal
team and of course the widespread
international support we can see it here
today particularly from Israel and the
women's rights movement in Cyprus
she has persevered she cannot thank
highly enough those people who've
contributed including John Hobbes to her
crowdfund and for the kind messages of
support and belief which have
volunteered at her truth she has asked
in fact that I thank everyone on her
behalf she wishes to thank her wonderful
parents the Foreign Office who have done
so much within the last week and her
legal team Michael Pollock from justice
abroad myself Lewis Eric you see
Nicoletta Harry Lambie do and Ritzer
peccary who collectively have worked
tirelessly in the pursuit of justice on
her behalf the time for her to return to
her home to the UK as long a virtue she
needs to be with her family to be given
the psychological help and treatment
which has been denied her thus far not
only has she been incarcerated and
nicosia prison but she's also been
subjected to the most stringent of field
conditions and we'd also like to thank
dr. Christine
from the UK who has assessed diagnosed
and prescribed her need for immediate
treatment what this case has
specifically highlighted is a giving
cousin in the specialized treatment
sexually assaulted women rectums in
Cyprus on the UK judiciary's clearly
their husband to this point that's time
and fact still is a deficit in the
provision of her protocol on
safeguarding and in this case we say
there was a specific failure which led
to a catastrophic situation with the
victim finding herself as the accused
being denied access the appropriate
legal and medical care indeed a lawyer
and the translator were not even
provided Westone to interrogation we
also say that this case will have
far-reaching repercussions for women
travelling abroad and that has
highlighted the need for appropriate
representation this young woman has
shown a man's bravery courage and
fortitude and coming forward her
identity has been compromised
she has been trolled viciously on social
media and has been subjected to violence
some of those who perpetrated the
serious sexual assault returned to their
homeland bragging triumphantly and
honesty madly as to what they had done
to her compounding her trauma there will
be people who will by their heads and
him and respect of this kiss but not her
finally we as a civilized society cannot
allow this blame the women victim
culture to continue and let the
perpetrators go unpunished this in fact
is the greatest injustice of all